hey everybody this is jeff posnick from
the youtube developer relations team and
we're continuing a series of videos
about the migration between the older
legacy version of the YouTube data API
v2 onto the newer version of the data
API v3 we strongly encourage folks to
begin that migration process if you
haven't done so yet and we wanted to
highlight certain types of functionality
and talk about the v2 way of doing
things and how you would go and do the
same sort of thing in v3 we're going to
start by talking about how you would
actually get a list of videos that are
in a given channel using v3 the data API
folks familiar with v2 the data API know
that you do this pretty much with a
single restful api call you look for the
user uploads feed for a given channel
and you get back a list of videos you
know by default and XML format although
you could also ask for it in JSON format
if you want in v3 involves slightly
different set of operations and it's
just kind of keeping with the overall
philosophy with v3 in that you return
you know a very specific set of
information for a specific API call
rather than returning a lot of
information so it's a little bit more
focused API and the other main
difference is that in v3 we work
primarily with channel IDs rather than
legacy user names so if you're familiar
with the more v2 way of doing things
where every channel had a legacy
username you know you need to kind of
start thinking about channel IDs instead
and this is particularly important
because moving forward not every channel
does have a legacy username so if you
didn't want to uniquely identify any
given Channel there you know arguably
those channels that don't have legacy
usernames and you do need to get
comfortable working with channel IDs
so let's actually walk through the steps
of doing the operation of getting the
uploads in a channel using Version three
of the API and we're going to switch now
to a screen share that I have up and
what I have open here is the Google API
Explorer
this is a great resource for playing
around with version 3 of the data API or
you know using our analytics API or any
other of the modern Google API s and
gives you a way making API calls within
the context of this nice browser web
form and trying out different parameters
so when you are actually writing code
for using this sort of thing in your own
applications you're probably gonna want
to use our client libraries but this is
kind of a neutral agnostic way of
showing off the API calls so that being
said there are two different steps for
getting the uploads in a given channel
assuming that you know we're going to
assume right now that we know that
channels legacy username the first step
is to get back the playlist ID that
corresponds to the uploads for that
channel and the way we do that is by
making a YouTube channels list call and
we have that open here in the API
Explorer and when making version 3 API
calls pretty much the convention that
all the list operations follow is that
you have one parameter called part and
you set this to a value that is a little
bit dependent upon the given method in
this particular case the YouTube
channels that list takes these values
over here in the documentation we
describe exactly what all of them do and
what we want is the content details part
so instead of returning every single
piece of information that we know about
the channel in every API response which
could get very bloated you have to
explicitly state what kind of
information you want to get back and you
get a nice really compact API response
back so we're going to say we want the
content details part back and this is
how we get the uploads playlist I do
and there's this parameter called for
username as the documentation states it
lets you pass in a legacy YouTube
username assuming that the channel that
you're interested in has one and it will
return information corresponding to that
channel so this is kind of like a
shortcut of getting information about a
channel or looking up the channel's ID
if all you know is the legacy username
so in this particular case we're going
to look up the Google developers channel
that's the legacy username and we're
gonna scroll down a bit we don't need
any of these other fields right now and
click execute and it's making the API
call for us you'll see these are the
parameters this is the actual restful
URL that's being requested and you get
back this JSON response and you'll see
over here because we're only asking for
information about one specific channel
the items return array only has one
elements not surprisingly you do get
this channel ID right here if we you
know did want to use that information
later on that might be useful but in
particular context of what we're doing
here we want the uploads playlist ID so
I'm going to just copy that if you're
writing real code you would obviously
save it to a local variable and use it
in a follow-up call and I'm going to now
make another API call and just open up a
new tab for that and this is going to be
a YouTube playlist items list
and you know again the thing to keep in
mind is that in Version three of the API
many things are considered playlists
like if you instead of in version two
where you would go and get specifically
the uploads feed corresponding to a
given channel in Version three you first
look up the playlist that corresponds to
the uploads for the channel and then you
do the standard YouTube playlist items
list call and this is the same API call
that you would use if you were getting
information about you know a
user-generated playlist
it's really quite equivalent so you'll
see that a lot in version 3 of the API
where we kind of reuse methods or kind
of overload the the function of methods
so that they could be used for a variety
of different operations so in this
particular case we have this part primer
again I'm going to pass in the value
snippet here and snippet is a part of
that it contains the most relevant
information about any given response
item the things that would be useful if
you were to for instance want to display
information about the response like in a
web browser so it'll contain like the
title for each item it'll contain a
thumbnail will contain a description and
that's type of information that we want
about all the uploads in a given channel
so I am going to take that copied
playlist ID and I'm going to paste it
into the playlist ID field this is
something to really keep in mind you
want this into playlist ID parameter
there's a separate parameter called ID
and that takes in something that's
different than the playlist ID so please
you know this common source of confusion
make sure that you're setting the
playlist ID parameter in this particular
case and I'm also going to set max
results to fifty one of the things
you'll notice is that max max results is
by default set to five inversion through
the API which is fine if you are going
to be you know displaying the results on
a web page and you don't want a really
really long list of videos but you know
in this particular case I want to get in
about as many as I could in a single API
call and most you could get back is 50
and click execute at this point and
scroll down and you'll see this items
array similar to what we saw for the
previous one but in this case the items
array has multiple items in it because
there are not surprisingly quite a few
uploads in the Google developers Channel
you'll have information about like when
that upload was published and titles
descriptions of some nails things I
mentioned before one other thing that I
wanted to point out is the way paging
works in version 3 of the API because
this is something that's different than
version 2 as well so previously in
version 2 you could kind of pass in
whatever you wanted as the start index
and that will allow you to jump to
different places within something like
an upload speed in version 3 of the API
we don't take in a start index parameter
we take in what's known as a paging
token and that gets returned in the API
response and it's used when you build up
your next request as a way of saying hey
you know I've gotten this page of
results give me the next page results
this allows for our certain efficiencies
on the server and it means that you get
a more reliable paging experience when
you're using version 3 it just allows
things to be a little bit more efficient
and it means that less likely to be
duplicates or things that are unordered
so let's actually take in that next page
token value from this response and we're
going to construct the next page of
requests by pasting it in here so we're
going to have all the same parameters
but we're sending page token now and if
I click execute
things should return back but in this
particular case I get a different set of
results this is basically results 51
through 100 and we can continue doing
that basically as long as there's a next
page token returned that means that
there is another page a result of
results that you could get back and you
could loop more or less until you stop
getting back next page tokens as soon as
that stops being returned you know that
you've reached the end of the list so
hopefully that's a good overview for how
you would do something in version 2 and
then how you would do the v3 equivalents
stay tuned for future shows they cover
more topics and version 3 of the API and
thanks so much for joining us again i'm
jeff posnick
from the developer relations team and
stay tuned Cheers